welcome to this video playing Casanova
from from the US Calvin wrong okay so we
get down in the English opening he
played this the nymphs of which the
names of each line against will see 45 a
bit of a strange water but it's am it's
an online what I'm trying to do with a
six is two to keep the Bishop Bishop c5
Bishop e7 this kind of this kind of idea
ok let's go there first it also prevent
Bishop g5 ideas maybe I can go Queen d7
unter try to Castle long its Queen d7
insane me okay let's try that maybe if
it takes money doesn't it's not even
thinking about that it's like you for
good
age 5 i'd like to do something something
out of the ordinary him
if i go back to h7 unprepared five
mm-hmm let's let's try that
nice playing a very quickly f5 okay
let's get off first
yeah interesting this could be for some
ideas f5 night back to f6 opening up the
F file young be five wow he's preventing
a five with some some very serious
measures weakening the kingside in the
process okay I kick this night
so it's returning and now be five this
is a typical counter play against this
confirmation I'm attacking the c-4 pond
and if he captures it opens up the a
file so nothing that wide um likes to do
okay so he's just giving this up maybe
trying to get some tech going the night
on f5 is always dangerous that's hardly
a position where you have a night where
knight on d5 is positioned and where
there's nothing really there's always
some kind of some kind of plate okay
watch what to do probably I should hack
it off let's get rid of this piece and
gain this game this pony so on how to
continue he probably has got F for
coming
okay occupy the center it's not bad I
guess f4 have a phone I don't think that
you can take a six this looks really
cheeky grabbing the porn I have 92 at
least 92 yeah so FYI go efore Queen
moves on the night back to be five or
something
yeah not not much use in spending time
yeah I just noticed that my queen on g7
is unprotected so maybe he can take only
four bit at the end his king is also a
liability aha this is interesting with
whatever d4 right okay d phi can he can
under I cannot F Knight f6 with the
temple so he couldn't take on you for so
this is yeah just protect here and isn't
this completely overwhelming I've got
those two points here yeah he doesn't
really have any play I think ok Knight
f6 yeah maybe that's even g5
Knight f6 g5
the g5 I have III young man my queen now
is protected so we should be 3d III is
playable and then next move I can go to
d5 only wonder should i do this now or
should I take first here wait if I take
take Bishop be a check I know here he
always I have night h5 though wait this
is good I can give this check here check
and then gunite h5 I don't need to need
to retreat passively I can play this act
of them and check
so warm I'm threatening but should be
eight now really I can take h3 now as
well at least I can do that or is there
something better Jack Kim take it so
what now Queen Queen g3 simply check
just something on on edge agent rook h8
or just like a check like rap I grab all
this check it's it's simpler check check
ok so how to how to do this now this
should be eight isn't isn't really
helping so I just I just give this up it
doesn't really matter
those pawns and everything is so
overwhelming now rook edge for coming
this really was indefensible I think
check
white resigns yeah I did or kept at all
I began to fall apart him after after be
five after that I don't know it's it's
it's tricky he needs to do something
else yeah I guess I think Whitehead I
had a really nice position I mean this
this must be must be quite okay for
white just with more moves okay this
wasn't bad but but G from already i
don't know it i don't really like the
move I'd like to prevent and prepare
something along the lines of f4 with
white but the Sun here i'm already a
substantially better and this some yeah
this really am gave away a lot too much
too much more of the center yeah
blackest black is already a already
winning here onwards it was it was just
just tricky bit tricky yeah i can now
play that because after takes takes the
queen is protected by by the night oops
no like that so on this wasthis was
possible and this is like one way to
check to win probably a head-to-head a
maid or check chanting better even
around here yeah i had so check had this
one to be honest i don't understand ok
ok now i understand if white takes of
course yeah this kind of an idea yeah I
didn't see that I just check check
graeme check one more porn and just let
him take its no way that white is going
to defend this position with no king
King shelter and the center points yeah
computer gives minus 9 ok alright thanks
for watching